Hey playing a little Gaga but more
importantly um something interesting
happened today that I thought would be
interesting to talk to you guys about
come on can you zoom in on this can you
get it um introdu mom there's an awesome
guy today can you see mom don't really
like where Gary B's brand is going
definitely starting to lose the personal
touch so you know that came through a
couple minutes ago and you know I
replied and said head room right here
what's the scene so he'll probably get
back to me and you know maybe I missed
the email or you know I don't know what
it is but I highly doubt that you know
my personal touch has gone any lower
it's only gotten up I barely sleep
anymore I'm sick all the time because I
don't sleep and you know clearly
somebody brought up something
interesting as well and they should give
a shout-out to them because I thought
they brought up a good point right off
of that tweet I responded right away you
know his his came through at ten minutes
ago mine came seven minutes later so I
guess I was three minutes in between and
then coxy money says oh no that was a
retweet Eliot TP Eliot P brings up a
very good point
he says you think the personal touch is
really scalable I guess that's why I'm
doing the video today I'm really curious
what you guys think and I think what
really gets interesting to my point
where a child gets in a minute is she we
jumped in and said I thought Gary Vee
was quite real and personable when he
spent time with the read SM group via
Skype late on Friday night which is a
small group I did something we're on
skype you know five or six people on a
Friday night at 9:30 I think it's quite
interesting I am of the belief that
effort is enough I hear from so many
people like Elliot that you know being a
personal brand or caring or doing it by
yourself is not scalable and
mathematically you know I understand I
agree don't worry let's slam don't write
story I'm not scared of it sourcing no
works um I think I think effort is
massively underrated
I think effort is something that does
allow your personal caring your customer
service if you're a big brand or your
personal interaction if you're a
one-person brand
scale because see here's what's
interesting you know no doubt you can't
cover everybody
you just can't but if you're covering as
many as you can and always trying to do
it for every person that comes out and
says you jumped a shark
you've sold out you don't care well BAM
oh you know this is a open conversation
social media world whatever you want to
define this so for everybody who says
something well anybody has the ability
to jump back in and say something as
well and so now all of a sudden you know
she wheeze conversation is quite
interesting because she's gonna say
Garrity on a Friday night in December at
in the midst of a 40 city tour gone on
skyper night at 9:30 at night with six
of us and interacted for a half an hour
that's not scalable that's something all
my advisers would advise against but I
love people see I can't lose and
everybody's got a different level of how
much they love and don't and on that
real scale is going to really determine
how interactive and how in there they
are because it's hard work but I find it
quite fascinating then I massively
believe that most people are under
estimating effort I do think effort
because it's so transparent now in the
new world where everybody has a voice
does allow to some level your customer
service your personal brand your one
person to scale what do you think